is if it was a food tiger belly or maybe
dinner or something like that but yeah
yeah yeah but i don't have i still order
a lot of entrees yes
well is that a thing you know i remember
it tennessee williams the catastrophe of
success
williams the catastrophe of society
yes i order a lot of entrees i like that
yeah
spade does the same thing yeah yeah i
like it do you do it i don't i'm from
one in ten from i'm from the depression
how do you feel about him not allowing
anyone to take home leftovers is that
true oh yeah oh is that true now i like
how he won't answer now well no no no no
no no no no well i'm done no i'll tell
you why i climbed up because i climbed
up because i've changed that about
myself yeah
no don't do that no i just remember
before he would like yell at us if we
tried to take like why or ask for a box
before
because
if i'm paying for it
just here's what i don't i've changed
that and now i let people do it because
i'm going against my behavior you did
not let jules and i take home sununu
that was different though
i'll tell you what that was different
different dish baby different dish no
pot okay go ahead of stew can i tell you
why yeah right we sunung dang it is a
korean restaurant on western right and
we got i thought it was a korean porn
star
i love sit on deck yeah and um we were
going to go to the spa afterwards right
so if you take korean food and i just
got that car that one that you made fun
of yeah yeah you call it delia car
deleon
yeah from five years ago yeah deleo 2019
2016.
yeah so um we're gonna go to the [ __ ]
spa yeah and if we're gonna be there for
two three hours i don't want korean food
just stinking up my brand new car oh
that's right that's the dish well you
could have brought it into the spa
anyhow yeah
would you want that sitting in your car
for three hours i would have brought it
into the sauna
[Laughter]
yeah uh yeah i get that i'm on your side
don't box it but the reason why i didn't
because is because
you know i would i would i was i always
paid for the meal
so i would always pay for somebody like
an opener right i think i see we're
going with this and then you don't want
them no after the meal they would just
grab it and take it to go and i'm like
hey dude you didn't ask
i paid for that that's my food
i mean
i'm just thinking sometimes i have an
entourage a real
i gotta be honest with you buddy i know
but i'm changing that about myself okay
okay because it it it dawned on me right
you know the the the the the idea was
entrenched in my mind
and um i thought that's weird and it's a
behavior that i don't like about myself
and so now it's like aside from that
situation that was an anomaly right um
from now on i've had many meals where
i've said go ahead take it
it's hard
i i mean when i say it's like you know i
have to go just take it
and i have to think about it and like go
calm bob relax you're changing
like in the last six months i've been
trying to change so much about myself
that it's like um i can't live the way
i've been living
um and um i have to
i want to be free well the but it was
also you just weren't expressing most of
your feelings right
yeah
i mean it was you're like you because
that's
like like like boundaries right right
like you know if a comic does something
like for instance
the newest one was
comics bumping me mm-hmm right and
normally i heard your case and i liked
it thank you yeah normally thank you so
much yeah yeah normally i would i mean
that's a good that's a big class
distinction that's another one that's a
big i don't i look at orders i look at
how many spots people have like
let's see
where i stand yeah let's see what do you
think of me
okay because that's the only